we are told consider the complex number
z which is equal to the square root of
17
times cosine of 346 degrees
plus i sine of 346 degrees
and they ask us to plot z in the complex
plane below
if necessary round the point coordinates
to the nearest integer
so i encourage you to pause this video
and at least think about where we would
likely
plot this complex number all right now
let's work through it together
so when you look at it like this you can
see that what's being attempted is a
conversion from
polar form to rectangular form
and if we're thinking about polar form
we can think about the
angle of this complex number which is
clearly 346 degrees
and so 346 degrees would be about would
is about
14 degrees short of a full circle
so it would get us probably something
around
there and then we also see what
the magnitude or the modulus of the
complex number is right over here square
root of 17
square root of 17 is a little bit more
than 4 because 4 squared is 16.
so if we go in this direction let's see
that's going to be about 1
2 3 4.
we're going to go right about there so
if i were to just
guess where this is going to put us it's
going to put us
right around here right around 4
minus 1 i but let's actually get a
calculator out and see if this evaluates
to roughly
4 minus 1 i so for the real part
let's go 346 degrees
and we're going to take the cosine of it
and then we're going to multiply that
times the square root of 17.
so times 17 square root
little over four which is equal to that
actually yes the real part does look
almost exactly four especially if we are
rounding to the nearest integer it's a
little bit more than four
and now let's do the imaginary part so
we have 346 degrees
and we're going to take the sine of it
and we're going to multiply that times
the square root of 17
times 17 square root
which is equal to yup if we were around
to the nearest integer
it's about negative 1. so we get
to this point right over here which is
approximately
4 minus i
and we are done